willkommen zur heutigen sitzung diesmal
auf deutsch wieder über künstliche
intelligenz in der disziplin ihre
perspektiven ich gebe mal gleich zu
beginn ein vor blick auf das was uns vor
allem den studierenden eth zürich
studieren das sind herzlich weiterhin
eingeladen daran teilzunehmen noch
bevorsteht im restlichen verlauf dieses
semester ist heute geht es um ki und
ästhetik der nächsten sitzung behandeln
wir nochmal wir hatten schon mal ein
bisschen behandeln wollen sie noch ein
bisschen ausführlicher machen künstliche
intelligenz und autonomie
selbstbestimmung und robotik fokus auf
bot also auch wirklich roboter wie sie
in unserem alltag vorkommen hier hat
kathrin mittelheim zwei interessante
bücher geschrieben auch ein ganz neues
buch das werden wir behandeln dann
kommen wir zur frage nach künstliche
intelligenz und dem post humanismus post
humanistische tendenzen klang immer
wieder mal an in dieser sitzung am 25
januar werden wir ihm eine ganze sitzung
widmen diesen fragestellungen die auf
der hand liegen wenn man es mit kaffee
zu tun habe in diesem rahmen werden wir
auch weiter fragen inwiefern ki und
anthropologie sich zueinander verhalten
also nicht nur post humanismus auch
humanismus grundsätzlich im sinne der
anthropologie das meint das verhältnis
von mensch zu
künstlich kite im weitesten sinne zu der
ja auch künstlich intelligenz gehört und
versuchen zu erörtern inwiefern
künstliche intelligenz vielleicht schon
vorläufer tradition hat im rahmen einer
anthropologie oder ob künstlich
intelligente wege was anthropologische
neuartiges ist was den menschen einer
ganz neuen situation erscheinen lässt
das ist mir selbst aber nicht ganz klar
das müssen wir in dieser sitzung
diskutieren
in der vorletzten sitzung am ersten
februar kommen nochmal auf ethische
probleme von ki zu sprechen wir hatten
schon ein paar tendenzen angesprochen
wir hatten dieses oxford handbook auf
die fx oft nach oben rechts ein linker
zu sein und am 8 februar den letzten
sitzung diskutieren noch mal
rückblickend zu allen fragen sie können
fragen einbringen wir werden auch noch
mal die diskussion mit youtube
revue passieren lassen der maria oben
rechts den linken die ist jetzt online
und fand ich auch ein interessantes
erlebnis das ist jedenfalls der plan für
den rest des semesters heute geht's
jetzt aber mitten ins thema hinein
nämlich um die frage nach der
künstlichen intelligenz in ihrer
ästhetischen kompetenz sagen jetzt mal
das was sie hier sehen haben einige von
ihnen vielleicht schon gesehen einige
vielleicht auch noch nicht das ist davon
wohl so sagen das teuerste bild was geht
und künstliche intelligenz erzeugt und
eben auch verkauft wurde sie können sich
mal überlegen was sehen sie darauf wir
diskutieren das bild dann auch genauer
im seminar an anschluss ja was ist jetzt
zu sehen eine person wahrscheinlich
männlich mit einem weißen faden
schwarzen haaren etwas verschwommen
trotzdem kann man hier die augen sehen
die nase den mund so erahnen hier unten
ist ein algorithmus
verzeichnet und ich komme jetzt noch
genauer darauf zu sprechen warum was
sich ja eigentlich handelt das ist das
porträt toff edmund de bel ami und
dieses gemälde von ki wurde im oktober
2008 10 vom auktionshaus christie's für
sagenhafte
1500 us-dollar versteigert das war ein
vielfaches des ursprünglich erwarteten
erlöses also wirklich eine stange geld
und es wurde mit hilfe des im bild unten
rechts angegeben algorithmus erstellt so
sieht er aus und
dieser algorithmus kann man diesen
besteht aus zwei komponenten des
hochinteressant der algorithmus ist
gewissermaßen dialogisch verfasst
aufgesplittet einen generator und einem
diskriminiert so bezeichnen sie
jedenfalls die
ingenieure dieser kann das system wurde
mit über 15.000 porträts also bildnissen
von personen aus dem zeitraum vom 14 bis
zum zwanzigsten jahrhundert gefüttert
das ist die datengrundlage und auf
dieser basis
erzeugt der generator ein neues bild
also auf basis dieser 15.000 porträts
damit gewaltige daten kommt lage
überzeugt er ein neues bild und dem
diskriminiert diese andere teilaspekt
der ki musste dann versuchen darin ein
wirkliches von menschen gemaltes bild zu
erkennen also die ki hat sich praktisch
selbst
ausgetrickst das war das ziel sollte
sich selbst vorgeben ein menschliches
bild konstruiert zu haben klingt jetzt
ein bisschen schizophren
aber so hat man das versucht zu
konstruieren dass also der
diskriminierende glauben sollte dass das
was der generator ihm davor liegt ein
wirklich von menschen gemacht bild ist
und das was der gegner der
diskriminierten am ende für ein von
menschen gemaltes bild hieß geht das ist
das bild was wir gesehen haben das ist
dieses porträt und das interessante an
diesem porträt ist dass es von deren
menschlichen vorstellung eines porträts
aus dem 18 jahrhundert abweicht also sie
haben schon gesehen es ist ein bisschen
unscharf es hat aber doch eher was
zeitgenössisch ist also man würde
niemals denken dass wir mit dem 1800 zu
einem porträt gemalt haben würde es hat
was zeitgenössische ist wirklich
modernes an sich und es ähnelt wie
wissenschaftler festgestellt haben den
bildern eines modernen künstlers glenn
brown der auch ältere bildnisse
aufbereitet hatten auf die aktuelle zeit
bezogen hat das ist zum beispiel ein
porträt von glenn brown was ich nämlich
fand man sieht hier auch andeutungen
augen und den augen mund partie fand ich
ziemlich ähnlich zu dem porträt von bel
ami
es ist ein bisschen verfremdet aber
trotzdem hat es was klassisches das ist
so mein eindruck müssen genau noch
darüber diskutieren wie sie persönlich
dieses bild empfinden das ist die quelle
christie's als das auktionshaus hat
diese information zur verfügung gestellt
damit sie noch auf ein weiteres
ästhetisches phänomen eingehend
vielleicht haben sie schon damit bekommt
das beethoven
x10 de ein projekt das soll also der
beethoven sein und um was handelt es
sich es geht um beethovens zehnte
sinfonie die unvollendet
geblieben ist er hatte einige skizzen
dazu angefertigt aber sie ist nicht
vollständig durchkomponiert überliefert
vorne als beethoven und 127 staat
gehörten zu seinem nachlass 40 skizzen
für diese zehnte gut 50 sind und jetzt
hat ein team von experten für
maschinelles lernen und
musikwissenschaft diese skizzen genutzt
um eine ki zu entwickeln die geben das
vollenden sollte was beethoven
altersbedingt nicht mehr gelingen konnte
die herausforderung dieses karten
projekt besteht darin dass die ki ein
musikalisches thema oder ein motiv über
mehrere tage hinweg beibehalten und
sogar weiterentwickeln und variieren
musste
die forscher sagen dazu die dieses
projekt erstellt haben es ist ungefähr
so wie wenn man eine nachricht auf dem
handy verfasst zb sap und dann immer die
nächsten wörter vorgeschlagen bekommt
die sich eben
eingespielt haben auf basis der
bisherigen einkauft ich gehe danach
konnte der vorschlag in
die schule das problem ist nur dass
diese prognosen auf basis der bisherigen
daten also diese 40 skizzen dass die
ziemlich
kurzatmig szene als man hätte da
vielleicht drei vier fünf takte mit
solchen
üblicherweise generierten prognosen aber
drei vier takte fünf takte das genügt
nicht um ein thema ein motiv wirklich zu
entwickeln also es muss über mehrere
takte ganze riesige böden hinweg eine
entfaltung dieses motivs geben und hier
kann dann noch programmierer ins spiel
die die kg unterstützt haben diese lange
atem zu beweisen das war eine
herausforderung sagen die entwickler und
eine weitere herausforderung bestand
darin die ki zu trainieren ja auf
welcher basis trainieren wir jetzt die
ja nicht nur auf basis der 40 skizzen
die sind ganz entscheidend für die
zehnte ist geht die zehnte alles reicht
ich müssen praktisch die ki
wie beethoven bilden das war ein kleines
bildungsprojekt und erst wurde sie wie
der junge beethoven trainiert also im
kontext der musik des 18 jahrhunderts
beethoven ist ja eher ein komponist des
19 jahrhunderts des frühen 19 man hat
ihnen im kontext dieser musik des 18
jahrhunderts
trainiert diese ki das war der anfang
und dann wurde sie immer mehr auf
beethovens eigenes werk in trainiert
seine frühen werke
man hat hier auch ein gen ethischen
aspekt mit einbezogen in das training
der carry hochinteressantes thema wie
trainiert man kann nicht einfach alle
daten zusammen
beethovens gesamtes werk sind muss er
mit genetischer strukturiert sein wann
die hochinteressant und dann wurde erst
um das ganze werk zu vollenden
die generelle melodie produziert also
auch hier wurde wieder die cani
zweigeteilt während ihr es zu einem
delikt sich entwickeln lassen an diesem
langen atem da versucht zu entwickeln
die eine melodie die eine melodieführung
die über das ganze becken weg geht und
ein anderer teil der ki hat dann
gewissermaßen die an vertikale
harmonisierung und orchestrierung dieser
horizontal verlaufenden melodie
unternehmen arbeitsteilung kann die
arbeitsteilung kreative arbeit zahlen
also ich fand es hochinteressant und
jetzt sind sie bestimmt gespannt wie
sich das anhört quelle ist bbc
zahlungsverkehrs michael sinn ich habe
ihn mal hier ein ton beispiel hier sehen
sie das cover dieser cd finde ich auch
ganz interessant hier beethoven zur
hälfte die büste und das andere klingt
wie so sieht so aus wie
schallwellen oder wie ja irgendwie
digitalen
dimensionen von
stücken von digitalen stücken und nicht
spielen das mal vor ich hoffe es ist
genug
[Musik]
und so weiter das stück das ist jetzt
der gab das kerze dritte oder vierte
sinfonie können sich anschauen auf
youtube
interessant interessant ist dass in
dieser sinfonie plötzlich eine orgel
erklingt und wir haben kritikerinnen und
kritiker gesagt beethoven hatte orgel
der hass er hätte sie nie eingesetzt für
seine sind von ihm interessant warum die
künstliche intelligenz jetzt drauf kommt
orgel das instrument der orgel hier
einzubeziehen hören sich nur an gänze
sehr interessant ja soviel zur
musikalischen ästhetik das ist jetzt das
was man mit ki gemacht hat und das ist
sicherlich noch lange nicht das ende
aber es gibt ganz verschiedene
modelle des verhältnisses von ki und
künstlerinnen künstler im sinne einer
symbiose einer
mensch-maschine-interaktion ich finde
diesen begriff mensch maschine
interaktion nicht adäquat für dieses
komplexe verhältnis weil es nicht nur in
die interaktion ist sondern sich auch
eine inspirations verhältnis
man muss es genau analysieren und wenn
sich dieser frage ist ein buch
erschienen dann mit dem titel
götterdämmerung kunst und künstliche
intelligenz finde ich auch sehr
interessant hier auf das künstliche der
künstlichen intelligenz im sinne der
ästhetik mal einzugehen häufig wird ja
das künstlich nicht im ästhetischen sinn
verstanden sondern im sinne des
simulieren oder
ersetzen aber meine sinne dieses
ästhetischen spannendes gibt eine neue
reihe zu sehen sollten keine kritik oder
kritik und dieser reihe ist eben dieses
buch erschien und daraus wollen wir
heute ein aufsatz gemeinsam diskutieren
und dazu gibt es ein paar leitfragen 400
tage bilden aber danach er nur drei
gruppen auf welchen feldern der kunst
macht sich kaum bemerkbar
und welcher form wir haben jetzt schon
zwei fälle diskutiert
einmal die bildende kunst einmal die
tonkunst wenn man so nennen möchte es
gibt aber sicherlich noch ganz anderen
feldern dann inwiefern können wir ki
ästhetische autonomie zu schreiben wir
hatten schon die generelle frage
diskutiert inwiefern die akademie zu
schreiben jetzt kann man mal mit frage
spezifizieren nach künstlicher
intelligenz und ästhetischer autonomie
dann wie können wir die mensch maschine
interaktion und der ästhetischen
gesichtspunkten mehr bestimmen ich hatte
schon gesagt mir gefällt dieser begriff
mensch maschine interaktion nicht so gut
ich habe dann verschiedene gründe müssen
wir waren noch genauer behandeln also
man könnte hier zum beispiel fragen ist
es eine
eine einseitige verhältnis geht das
ganze immer nur für menschen aus oder
kann sich der mensch nicht auch
irgendwie inspirieren lassen oder kann
auch die ki inspiriert werden durch den
mensch ist eine symmetrische und
asymmetrische relation und dann noch
eine ähnliche frage wie die zweite frage
vielleicht ein bisschen genereller
gefasst und vision ist eine
algorithmische kreativität möglich auf
den ersten blick könnte man das ja
bestreiten man sagt algorithmen bisschen
starke verfahren das sind determinierte
prozesse bei determinierte prozesse
können so was wie kreativität überhaupt
nicht ermöglichen kreativität braucht
immer zufall und in der termin ismus hat
es scheint aufgegangen zu legen aber wir
müssen genauer fragen ob das auch stimmt
ja das sind die fragen vielen dank für
die aufmerksamkeit und wir gehen jetzt
in die diskussion über die ästhetik
künstliche intelligenz